[Music]
oh look at that I watched that tummy
shot and I was like that looks unreal I
think if you blast somebody with like
pressurized air that's what happens are
you sure oh wow whoa wow this is really
evolving like are they doing rear
projection for this or setting up some
sort of like image on a screen within
the set because that's what it seems
like to me
MPC made this with their in-house crowd
Sim tool called Alice there's two guys
in the same blue shirt
I see them yeah like look at the shot
yes we got a little glass refraction
sorry I mean
thanks to grammarly for sponsoring this
video
what's up everybody we have an awesome
react episode for you today but before
we get there I'm going to tell you about
today's sponsor grammarly as you guys
know I am the producer here at quarter
digital but I'm also the business
manager that means I talk to all the
different brands our react guests and
all outside communication at Corridor
for this reason I've actually been using
Grammy for years the first thing that
stood out to me for grammarly was the
typo fixer it's basically automatic and
it automatically tells you when it
senses a typo and you can literally just
buy a click of a button fix that type of
right then and there you actually use
Google Chrome all the time so they have
a browser extension it's simply download
and add to it and then anything you type
anything Chrome it gives you a little
red line if it senses a typo now that
I'm on grammarly premium program they
have amazing features that just help me
step up my communication year it's
called The Confidence tone suggestion
like this screen cap example right here
I wrote I think we should consider
rescheduling this meeting from this week
to next week the confidence tone
reframing suggestion just says let's
consider moving the meeting from this
week to next week it's straight to the
point you sound confident you can sound
professional through really cool tool to
help you reframe your sentences to come
off confident it's actually free to make
a grammarly account you can use the typo
correction feature right away if you go
to grambly.com you can get started right
now but if you'd like to up your game
and try out the confidence reframing
suggestion tool you can get grammarly
premium for 20 off if you use the link
in the description below it is a tool
that I believe you need to put in Your
Arsenal that's it for me happy riding
and now let's get to this awesome
reactor episode hey guys welcome back to
VFX artist react we have touchstar
crystals this morning we are filled with
positive energy I think we really don't
know the origins of the crystal yet but
it's to be determined in later episodes
of this show the point is we got some
clips we're rolling them Jordan's here
hello
I am here and I'm in the middle of these
guys which is actually the best place to
be yeah he's here to mix things up he's
here to bring a new spin to the show you
know bringing the spice back to bfx
artist reacts so you can count on him to
really bring us to the zingers today
what I'm here for boom is that your
takeover
first singer of the day in the bag
that's all I do I feel like that one's
been claimed I think you need a
different one we'll work on it
are we just going right into it I think
we should yeah cool let's do it I'm
excited
negotiations over
Judge Dredd awesome movie it came out 11
years ago it's crazy that we haven't
looked at it because it is a great
example of a movie with a ton of CG and
lots of practical stuff and it's a great
mix it's grounded approach to all the
effects in the movie
[Music]
oh yeah give me that some camera slow
motion everybody's on drugs everything's
slightly rainbow colored oh look at that
oh my gosh that's awesome and it doesn't
look like he has that much excess skin
so that must have been one heck of a
blast man
can you use a practical so they must be
hidden in their cannons that's what I'm
wondering what are they pelting him with
I watched that tummy shot and I was like
that looks unreal it doesn't look real
like a fake tummy like how real look how
much the skin is moving I think if you
blast somebody with like pressurized air
that's what happens are you sure like
around the like the lower belly area you
know I wouldn't be surprised if it's a
little warped warped yeah yeah that's
what it looks like to me too it looks
like a plastic bag
look at this nipple on the top right
there at the beginning it like almost
comes off it's it looks like his nipple
is about to pop off it's a lot of wind
she's getting hit with a lot of wind but
it's also probably very focused so I did
do some research on this shot and
they've said that that is real they used
insanely powerful air cannons to blast
everyone in this shot I don't know it
looks like around the hip especially
belly and hip it looks like there's some
warping going on especially at the end
there yeah I kind of feel like there's
some extra warping on top of it yeah
somebody's not going in there and like
making the ripples of the skin
themselves they're just taking the
overall form of the things
yeah distorting it they're giving it a
little bit of extra
liquefied-ness but it could also just be
a dude going
if he flies back I know we've done a lot
of like air cannons in people's faces
and stuff in slow motion and it looks
like that
we have some options here slow-mo guys
this is why humans are great right here
this is why you keep going you know
Humanity this is what Humanity has made
it where we've made it yeah there we go
yeah see that's that's what I'm looking
for those tiny ripples I mean the dude
might just have more skin I bet he was
surprised that's got to be a one take
wonder you don't do that twice it's got
to feel like you're getting punched when
that much air hits you all right Sam I
got a treat for you I know you love tiny
people I do your movies I know you love
it when it's also like retro VFX
[Applause]
that's all dolls and mirrors
oh so you're looking you're like oh my
God how'd they do it
[Music]
no shrinking man every day he wakes up
and he's a little bit tinier oh she
built it
she felt that's true love look at that
little guy hey look at that little guy
that has like the mangiest looking cat
it's actually like a famous acting cat
called orangey This Cat's in a bunch of
famous movies including this one does it
have an IMDb it does no way wow it also
won two Patsy's which is the pet version
of oscars that's the thing I didn't know
that that's a that's a thing
oh wow get it oh dude his back got
scratched oh wow wow this is really
evolving like are they doing rear
projection for this or setting up some
sort of like image on a screen within
the set because that's what it seems
like to me so he is literally just
standing in front of a movie screen and
they have projecting an image onto that
movie screen the Mandalorian is
basically a fancy version of what they
did here the new era LED walls things
like that this is basically the old
version of that so they're you know you
get to have a whole set you have to have
project you're like it's so complicated
to set this stuff up like the actual
visual effect that happens is simple but
everything else around it so complicated
and having like the knowledge like okay
light's going to come from here the
angle is going to look like this we're
gonna shoot everything deep focus so the
cat's in focus and he's in focus and it
doesn't look weird also it's a matter of
making sure your light that's hitting
your screen is bright enough to start to
match what your actual environment looks
like because once again it's like all
right imagine you're playing a video on
your TV and you're wanting to adjust the
brightness so that the white wall on
your TV is as bright as the white wall
in your room there's a lot of
calibration going into it a lot of light
meters and stuff and there's no screens
you're not looking at the screen on your
camera you're looking at a viewfinder
with a mirror that's reflecting it right
there's no digital screens there's no
checking your your exposure like you can
do it with light meters
mirrors and just like Grit
there were no spoiled these days it
blows my mind honestly about that one
shot of the cat coming inside and the
whole set shaking is the best shot in
this sequence for me this is a trailer
shot right here this is the kind of shot
you put in like the trailer people are
like I have no idea how you did this wow
the rest of these shots in a way like
they're not technically complicated
they're just really work intensive like
where they have to basically cut them
out they film him on some blank
background but then somebody goes in and
by hand cuts him out from every frame so
if you look closely on the edges you'll
see dark parts and you'll see bright
parts so when you have film and you're
exposing onto it when you want to put
two images onto a piece of film if
you've already exposed all of the film
and you project a new thing onto it you
end up with this double exposure and
that doesn't look good obviously things
get brighter when that happens in the
final result of the film so when you're
going to project a new element onto your
film you're going to be doing
compositing AKA visual effects you need
to keep that new part of the film or the
new element's gonna go in unexposed and
so that's when you use what's called a
hold out mat and it holds out that part
from being exposed it keeps it all black
and then you can black ask that with
your new image it basically gives you a
nice looking frame however if it's not
lined up perfectly you'll still see
black lines from the holdout mat not
being perfectly aligned and you'll see
bright lines where you're getting little
bits of Double Exposure where the new
image and the old image are slightly
overlapped how do you find this stuff
always comes out with these like crusty
gems that when you wipe them off have
like the most brilliant faceted Sparkle
to them this is all thanks to the
comments that people leave look I love
these crusty old clips if you have
something that's super old and forgotten
to the Sams of time let us know in the
comments below but you know what I got
more in my pocket Christian go the next
one
my experiments did not turn out quite
like yours Dr pretorius is going to show
us his homunculi wait humongous lie that
means multiple tiny mutants
wow that's cool sorry I mean
I've had they built the set to match
that's great was that a set so is he on
a transparent background nobody's
Shadows on the ground yeah I see his
hand on the table but I see a shadow on
the book but I also see some Shadows on
the table could they have rebuilt to
scale that table and book and just
pulled the whole thing no his
Reflections across the whole table and
the glass jars are reflected across the
whole table I wonder if they actually
have a shadow that they're like
compositing in but no you can't make
film darker with compositing you can
only make film lighter because as you
shine light onto film it breaks down the
Crystal and that's what lets light
through and makes white so you can't
like cover it up and make it Shadow so
that's not a set down below that's not
an oversized set like that is the
countertop yeah yeah I mean you can see
his Reflections in it there's no
reflections of the little dudes in the
desktop yeah yeah you can see that but
the fact that it reflects all the jars
just makes it feel like it's there man
oh wow they are just
relaxing bro 1935 this would inspire a
whole generation of filmmakers this one
shot is that just some just insanely
good tracking I think so yeah they're
just tracking him in there she won't
dance to anything but Wilson spring
sounds it's not even separated a shot
yes
yes and he's got like the stuff in front
of her too like there's no matting lines
or anything what's going on the
compositing is nuts it's Bonkers I'm
trying to look for the classic tells of
early compositing light edges dark edges
a little bit of frame Jitter but it's
like so smooth you know what I bet it's
going on here like this shot in
particular really shows it so you see
those the reflections slash wrinkles in
the glass or whatever that are kind of
on top of her when you're going to
expose onto a piece of film already
exposed as we mentioned you need to have
a hold out mat that's blocking that part
of the film from being exposed so she's
doing her little dance and you know it
spots blocked from being exposed his
shadow changes the refraction of that
highlight in the front so I think this
is a thing where the holdout mask it has
spots in it for the background to still
show through it's got a like the little
like stickers on the glass that's just
got to be cut out from the holdout mask
maybe it's real we haven't talked about
it but maybe it's real you know that's
always the possibility at the end of the
day yeah this was nice this was 19 1935
people were smaller back people were
smaller you're right that's a fact so
you know something about this feels to
me like the cleanest VFX from this era
that I've ever seen just the fact that
we are still struggling to figure out
what exactly their technique for some of
the reflections were means I mean it was
expertly well done whoever accomplished
this whatever team did this you know
what is this 90 years almost 100 years
old well done Bride of Frankenstein
we're gonna be looking at the comments
to see if anyone has a better theory on
how this was accomplished and once we
figure that out well we'll let you know
so make sure you subscribe we're getting
out of here
I'm taking those back to 2013. the good
old days I love simulations and one of
my favorites is crowd simulations
[Applause]
there's two guys in the same blue shirt
I see them yeah immediately they're
twins they're Brothers they stay
together yeah even when they're zombies
they stick together because they're
brothers that's the real story of World
War Z a lot of people missed it
the way that simulations work at the
base level is you have your initial
character models and you convert them
into what are called agents and those
agents are duplicated hundreds or
thousands or tens of thousands of times
to create these armies and when you have
so many thousands of people you don't
have so many thousands of models right
you're gonna see duplicates
in here you have thousands of zombie
agents that have the goal of climbing up
this geometry obviously up until this
point I'd seen a bunch of different
crowd simulations done in film like the
first one that comes to all of our minds
I'm sure is like Helms Deep and Lord of
the Rings right so HP games the creation
of the software massive to create these
agents that operate on a massive scale
and it's perfectly named but this was
like the agents in this Sim are acting
different than anything I'd ever seen
where they're literally crawling up each
other they're acting in whole new ways
driven by motivation it's the coolest
thing in the world where the motion data
that they have all these agents have is
climbing up nets they did motion capture
of climbing up ramps falling down ramps
so it's basically just triggering an
animation based on the position okay yes
but there's too much like animation
happening where I'm seeing that and that
can't be part of that system at this
point yeah you're totally right like
with these crowd simulations they are
limited in some respects you're going to
see like awkward things I know you guys
looked at Polar Express and you saw
those elves you'll see them avoiding
each other in Polar Express too they'll
kind of just like really directly like
avoid each other and so what's really
cool MPC made this with their in-house
crowd Sim tool called Alice at any point
they could take any agent and promote
them to what they call a hero where they
would send it to the animation
department and they would do custom
animation the really cool animations
like grabbing the guy's head and pulling
him back and then they do cloth
simulation on the top and then they
could plug them back into the simulation
the minute that you see people getting
close to screening these crowd
simulations the heroes start coming in
but all the other agents that are far
away from the camera are either climbing
falling down a ramp or it's triggering
ragdoll
it's really like they wash up against
the side like water too yeah they slam
up against the side like a lot of this
would be hand animation it would be
those Heroes that we talked about but
the flow of the characters their initial
goal was layout motion and flow of
Direction basically just trying to get
the initial like shape of water and then
they Sub in all the extra elements you
know the custom animation of a guy
landing and reaching out and getting
swallowed and just all integrated so
nicely to make this kind of stuff and it
blew me out of the water when I saw it
I'd never seen anything like this before
the whole art of visual effects when
stuff's lcg it's kind of like you're
watching a cartoon and it's giving you a
story but it's not necessarily
surprising you with like a magic trick
and when CGI and visual effects are like
photorealistically perfect then you're
starting to watch a magic trick and it's
like it's a different realm of like the
CGI I've generated this image rated like
convey sling to you that doesn't exist
versus like this is CGI I'm tricking you
into thinking this does exist but it
doesn't but I love it when you get a
little trick once in a while I guess on
the other side you have like Avatar
which is like okay it's CG and then you
just stop thinking about it as CG
because it's so CG and that you just
become used to seeing it but it's still
an animated film like Avatar still feels
like I'm watching a Pixar film from 30
years in the future Pixar is probably
going to take offense to that but
well I'm curious when the last Avatar
comes out that's supposed to take place
on Earth I believe yeah we have water
way of fire earth fire heart yeah Planet
wait is there heart wait is it actually
a fancy Captain Planet think about a
story it ends on planet Earth well then
what's the first one wind wind they fly
a lot yeah now it's hard the way of wind
which is secretly the name fire is an
Excellence volcano people fire water and
then Earth and then we kick off the
Captain Planet Cinematic Universe
Earth if they're going to ground it a
little more if they're going to go I
mean they probably won't is that a pun I
wish it was because then I would have
dropped a boom and everyone would have
loved it
now if your cereal bowl is still half
full and we're at the end of this
episode you can always hop over to
Corridor digital.com and get the
extended cuts and when it's just us on
the couch it's also us being a little
extra Goofy and laughing so you know
help you put a smile on that face
there's not already a big one there
already and you know what if you just
want more react right now and you don't
even sign up for the website that's fine
here's a playlist
just keep watching